QUESTION WAS INSULTING,
RIDICULOUS AND FRANKLY,
LUDICROUS.
>> RICH JENSEN, THANKS.
PLEASE JOIN ME SUNDAY NIGHT FOR
A LOOK AT HOW ANOTHER SUMMIT
THREE DECADES AGO CHANGE THE
WORLD.
IT COVERS RONALD REAGAN'S
EFFORTS TO REACH A AGREEMENT
WITH THE SOVIET MIKHAIL
GORBACHEV.
THAT'S BASED ON MY NEW BOOK,
"THREE DAYS IN MOSCOW."
HERE'S A PREVIEW.
>> WHEN I CAME IN IN 1982,
REAGAN WAS STILL IN FULL
THROATED RENUNCIATION OF THE
SOVIET UNION.
HE WAS STILL VERY MUCH PLAYING
THE COLD WAR ERA.
>> WHAT I'M DESCRIBING NOW IS A
PLAN AND HOPE FOR THE LONG-TERM.
IT WILL LEAVE AT MARXISM AND
LENINISM ON THE ASH HEAP OF
HISTORY.
FEW EVEN AMONG HIS ALLIES SHARED
HIS BELIEF THAT THE COLD WAR WAS
WINNABLE.
>> IT WAS A HUGE ARGUMENT IN THE
ADMINISTRATION.
PEOPLE IN THE DEFENSE DEPARTMENT
AND THE CIA BOTH THOUGHT IT WAS
A WASTE OF TIME.
WE ARE HERE, THEY ARE THERE, GET
A LIFE.
>> THE AMERICAN PUBLIC SEEM TO
AGREE.
NEARLY THREE QUARTERS FAVORED A
FREEZE BY THE UNITED STATES AND
SOVIET UNION.
>> I URGE YOU TO WEAR THAT
TEMPTATION OF PRIDE, THE
TEMPTATION OF DECLARING
OURSELVES ABOVE IT ALL.
>> THAT SPARKED REAGAN'S MOST
FORCEFUL CRITICISM EVER OF THE
SOVIET UNION.
>> TO IGNORE THE FACTS OF
HISTORY AND AGGRESSIVE IMPULSES
OF AN EVIL EMPIRE AND TO SIMPLY
CALL THE ARMS RACE OF GIANT
MISUNDERSTANDING AND TO THEREBY
REMOVE YOURSELF FROM THE
STRUGGLE BETWEEN RIGHT AND
WRONG, AND GOOD AND EVIL.
>> I WAS AT THE SPEECH WHERE HE
TALKED ABOUT THE EVIL EMPIRE AND
THE FOCUS OF EVIL ON THE MODERN
WORLD.
IT WAS STUNNING, EVEN BY
REAGAN'S STANDARDS, I WAS PRETTY